psychosis paralysis and strokes a study
shows the new corona virus could
seriously damage the brain and central
nervous system patients 7 reported
visual hallucinations seeing lions and
monkeys in her house patients 17
developed a headache on her right side
and her left hand went numb patient 11
had difficulties speaking then she
became disorientated and confused
[Music]
researchers are calling for more
extensive studies to investigate the
long-term risks for covered 19 patients
[Music]
surviving the corona virus is one thing
living with the consequences is another
for many who've suffered serious
symptoms rehabilitation poses its own
challenges dwz Nina hazard met a woman
who's slowly getting back on the road to
recovery and breathe the lung test at
the rehabilitation clinic is still
exhausting for Dorota danilevich this
berliner is a covert 19 survivor
very positive results here at the right
booked sia clinic near Magdeburg Dorota
danilevich is making great progress
although the past few weeks have been
tough in late May she was admitted to
hospital with bronchitis and a severe
fever an initial coronavirus test was
negative but after another test from her
lungs she was diagnosed with kovat 19
with severe pneumonia an inexperienced
doctor put her on a ventilator u.s.
momentous oozora tsubasa in Geelong girl
oh it feels at first like water running
into your lungs I was terrified and
feared for my life I almost had a heart
attack my heart hurt for hours
afterwards I screamed and cried I was in
real trauma for several days afterwards
it's been six weeks since her diagnosis
she spent the last two here there are
strict protective measures in place at
the clinic two people per table you
can't choose who you're eating with
Dorota danilevich is one of a handful of
excavate 19 patients the others here are
recovering from cancer or surgery
therapy here consists of physical
exercise breathing sessions and methods
of relaxation
Dorota danilevich spends a lot of time
here on the cross trainer initially she
only managed three minutes now she can
do 13 yes it's only been three days now
that I haven't had to sleep so much and
lie down during the day there is this
strange extreme tiredness after kovat
that I hadn't been aware of I just
assumed that after a few days at the
hospital everything would be all right
tiredness and a long lasting loss of
taste are typical symptoms after kovat
19 and first russian discussed what's
surprising for us is that the
polyneuropathy which is the damage done
to the nerves during kovat 19 massively
limits our patient's mobility the patent
and vocally must Seif by interesting in
their mobility one was isis fighters in
a psychological strain is also severe
they've survived a life-threatening
disease and they keep thinking about
what could have happened
most worse heta Alassane Cohen
Dorota danilevich spends a lot of time
thinking about her father he was in
hospital with cancer and the coronavirus
in the spring she was only allowed to
visit when he was dying two days after
his death she had the first symptoms
herself and couldn't attend his funeral
something she discusses with her doctors
here Monken Osmos Itanium 30% what we
have is time for our patients that's
something that occurred care
professionals just have very little time
for these days
we can give our patients the time they
need we listen to their problems so that
they can get these things off their
chest more and more former kovat 19
patients are being admitted to
rehabilitation centres in germany health
insurance companies have started
covering the costs to ease the pressure
on hospitals the rota danilevich is now
immune and feels liberated just a few
days ago I laughed out loud for the
first time that's when I thought oh here
I am again I can laugh out loud and from
the bottom of my heart that wasn't
possible for weeks she plans to get her
immunity tested regularly but for now
she's looking forward to life after
kovat 19 urologist CeraVe Tov joins us
she specializes in neurodegenerative
diseases explain to us exactly how the
virus attacks the brain oh you're
starting off with a very difficult
question that we as neurologists are all
scratching our hats around so I think
it's fair to say that it's still very
early in the era of neurological
manifestations of corvids and it really
comes down to the unknowns of this virus
it has just been discovered that can it
can have these devastating effects on
the nervous system really and one theory
is obviously that it enters via the nose
or and then goes into the brain directly
and this would be a direct viral injury
to the brain
another theory might be but it's not so
much the virus itself attacking the
brain but rather the immune system of
the body trying to clear the virus in a
healthy way and then going a little bit
over the top and causing quite
significant peri inflammation and
inflammation of the brain as an
over-over responds of the immune system
really another mechanism that we have
observed is targeting the stickiness of
the blood so it seems to me that person
severely affected with the kovat 19
virus is having an increased propensity
for the blood clotting so this can
obviously cause significant
really to the brain by a stroke and
mainly large vessel strokes so these are
just a couple of mechanisms and I think
there are several ones that we will
really need to make sure that we will
uncover them with future research I
don't know if this question is just as
hard but I know a lot of people will be
asking themselves is the damage
permanent so I think here again we have
to distinguish which sort of brain
damage it is we are talking about and in
a study we recently published and in our
experience with these patients it really
comes down to the mechanism and to the
early symptoms that people are reporting
so we have seen people that are getting
on very well with neurological confusion
syndromes or Enka philosophy as we as
neurologists might call them these
people have a temporary dysfunction of
the brain and in our follow-up studies
they are able to clear this temporary
dysfunction this confusion and this
delirium that they are having within a
couple of days really so an impressive
full recovery can be made however again
we have more severe cases where it comes
down to the virus in an indirect way
attacking via the blood vessel problem
the central nervous system causing
strokes or the peripheral nerves calling
something that we call youngberry
syndrome and again here recovery takes
way longer it's quite a hard
rehabilitation intensive pathway that
the patients are usually stepping on and
again it's too early to see what the
long-term effects of those will be and
the fourth category of patients the most
severe ones potentially that we've
observed was these direct inflammatory
severe changes in the brain and here the
outcome can potentially be fatal and
people can recover from it but there is
a higher likelihood that they will have
a residual neurological deficit after
recovery czar lastly and just briefly
what sort of patients are especially
affected in these cases so we've seen
the effects of Kovach 19 on the brain in
patients that had quite bad
chest and multi-organ effects of the
corona virus and we have seen this in
these people as they needed to be
intubated fully ventilated and as we
wean them off sedation and ventilation
you realized oh they are very slow to
wake up and this is a potentially a
secondary complication of their critical
illness and of their long time on ITU
interestingly enough we have also seen
the virus in people that were very very
mildly affected from a lung point of
view and from another organ point of
view and they had only presented to
hospital because of the severe
neurological manifestation that the
virus was triggering in those so it
seems to be quite unpredictable at the
moment and we can't yet really work out
why some people who have a very mild
lung respiratory illness then present a
couple of days later into their illness
intra neurological hospital presenting
with severe weakness or difficulty with
consciousness levels or coma salvadore
food you have to leave it there thank
you very much now more of your questions
our correspondent Derek Williams is
standing by to delve into the world of
medical science assuming different kovat
19 vaccines are successful on different
timelines what is the possibility there
will be multiple vaccines available
within a certain country the chances are
quite high actually um there are over a
hundred and fifty different vaccine
trials going on around the world and
over 30 of them are already in human
trials a few of them quite far advanced
down the road to approval
they're also based on a number of
different platform technologies which
will play a role in the crucial step of
production when and if they're shown to
be effective on a wide scale what are
known as messenger RNA vaccines would be
quite fast to produce but but the
technology is still pretty cutting edge
so knew that that if an mRNA vaccine is
approved for kovat 19 it would be the
first mRNA vaccine to be approved ever
for for a disease more tried and tested
technologies that rely on on small or
inactivated doses of a pathogen or or
proteins that it carries they take
longer to produce its scale but also we
have more experience with them making
them in some ways more likely candidates
for fast approval I think down the road
there's almost certain to be overlap
from from different vaccines in
different places
[Music]